next up
the best trash taste after dark episode
oh oh we're getting to the big awards
well you know obviously this year we
really like put our foot into after dark
yeah i think i know what's gonna win
this because yeah yeah denominations all
right let's see
i still love that thumbnail yeah the one
we try american snacks the one we rate
beers yeah uh the one the figure special
uh the uh fifth grader
yeah yeah yeah
uh the uno one which is very popular
yeah the role-playing one amazing stream
yeah yeah of course the charity stream
yes all of these are such great episodes
though yes i mean i i think it's obvious
which one's gonna win uh hey i mean yes
i think it's gonna be a 24-hour
challenge i think i think i would bet my
entire life savings on that this is
going to win yeah really yeah but like
i don't know they're like all good but
for like different reasons i mean
obviously with the research this is five
episodes in one yeah
i guess of course it's like also the
recency bias as well right yeah i just
think it was a really big and also there
were just so many [ __ ] amazing
moments from these we got all of the
best out of context clips and out of
context maybe i think it's like i would
i would be interested to see what do you
think would come second
i personally really like the trpg that
was like one of the funnest ttl uh that
was one of the finest trash takes after
dark yeah to film as well
like everyone was on point like yeah you
know karen was like top of the game yeah
yeah every everyone was hilarious it was
so great because it was just so on point
to connoisseur as well yeah like it was
literally like i watched the back i'm
like yeah damn we just made a
connoisseur episode just like live and
i'm just like how do we do this
unscripted i also named my character
after the mom from uh the hentai
masterpiece and no one noticed yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah um
but like yeah like i mean a quick word
about after dark i would have to say
like i think even like there's a point
where i think if you don't watch after
dark i actually think some of our best
content out this year came from after
dark you know uh i think because i think
initially we didn't have after dark
until the second half the year and a lot
of efforts a lot of our time and effort
was put into making after dark the best
that it could be you know you could
argue sometimes like we we
focus on that more on like the main show
at times because that's how like that's
how much we wanted it to get off the
ground um so you know if you don't watch
after dark please watch the vods there
are a lot of great moments and some of
the best moments of this year are in
after dark absolutely absolutely but uh
there can only be one winner though
let's find out
24 hour stream oh of course hold on
okay very nice what is up
what is up
i mean i it still blows my mind how much
was raised that day all right i remember
because i i remember thinking we set the
goal at 100k
and like about five hours in i was like
we've made a massive mistake we're not
gonna hit it
and then come comes out of the woodwork
let me help you yeah yeah so yeah what
was the percentage breakdown of that oh
49.7 percent yeah went to the 2400
charity stream yeah um second place was
the trpg stream yeah okay 15.1 yeah all
right that makes so much sense yeah
that's totally got that right yeah all
right what's uh the next category joey
all right well third to last
uh we have oh okay this one off as well
is a new one and is i think mostly after
dark related but we've done a lot of
quizzes
oh
okay and we've had some pretty [ __ ]
monkey moments so that's the dumbest
quiz answer
so yeah we've uh had a lot of
uh i guess dumb answers on the quizzes
yeah this is quizzes i was either like
insane or just boosted yeah yeah never
in between on the quizzes yeah this is
i mean like the quiz this is like a new
category for this year right so we
wanted some representation for some of
the new content that we started making
this year representation so i think we
should show these moments because i
think a lot of people wouldn't have seen
these moments because they didn't watch
after dark yeah so let's go let's check
out the next check out the nominations
well obviously uh we got a connor spells
nor
uh play the clip actually
oh n-g-h-a-w
fine yeah
like the because it was like a moment of
silence after he said that and it was
just like everyone in the room was just
processing what he said like could you
repeat that
not my proudest moment
you couldn't even hold in your laughter
you're just like could you feel that
i thought i thought you were joking at
first i was like no that was a mistake
right
[Laughter]
it was just like the extreme confidence
i said it was like oh yeah i just for
some reason i had the blinders on i was
so convinced that's how you spelled it
so good come on for the life of me
explain why
and then uh we obviously have uh the
boys give budweiser
we've already seen that one yeah uh the
baby one time
uh that was from the music quiz yeah
yeah yeah play the clip i thought baby
and one more time but i put stuff before
it so sure
you wrote baby one time
all right i will say i will say i got
[ __ ] over in this quiz by the way
because it was the staff that said to me
the song name was hit me baby one more
time the official name is baby one more
time i was just too [ __ ] monkey to
spend it out properly okay maybe once
but even if i put the right the right
name i still wouldn't have got the point
draws a house in the kanji quizzes
the next kanji is house
i think i've got this all right show it
off all right
if you see this you know what it means
i stand by that i stop if there if i
could re reinvent the kanji system i
mean i would be the house just be house
right just re-house
every everyone knew what i meant
everyone knew what i meant and then the
last one is uh this one the uh
oh this one the meme quiz right no no
this is from the game oh the gaming quiz
that's right which video game did the
meme press f to pay respects come from
my [ __ ] call of duty knowledge is
[ __ ] awful oh it's call of duty
you didn't know that
i said counter-strike souls
[Laughter]
see okay this clip uh this there's one
issue of trash taste after dark which is
like everything is live so we can't edit
afterwards yeah i remember seeing joey's
face of panic when i said oh it's called
do you guys just goes
yeah
because that wasn't caught on camera
because the camera was on me but joey
had just had like the biggest face of
panic and it was like so funny
it was very funny
yeah
because it's been nominated so much
just because it is an iconic moment
nor is my personal favorite no no it's
my personal favorite
i kind of don't want budweiser to win
because i don't want to relive that
moment anymore me would love to see the
ftp respect yeah yeah yeah
i don't think it will win yeah
what is that then all right the dumbest
quiz answer of trashes after dark is
connoisseur
[Laughter]
well you know what well deserved
honestly that was well deserved as well
i will never let you know is it at least
close it was really close oh really okay
that one with 26.9 percent of the vote
right uh joey's
pay have to pay respects
uh press f to pay respects came in
second with 26
oh wow
[Music]
but i mean i deserve it that was very
very dumb
and i have no recourse for it that was
just that's what it was at least it was
funny at least it was a good moment
you made a good moment